my name is Samuel leaves and you are
here with the property investors crash
course how many of you have come here to
receive some financial freedom over the
next two days I want you to step right
out of your comfort zone but let me tell
you something when you just step out
welcome to glory are you ready to step
out of your comfort zone yes
are you really have some fun and you're
going to make some money are you ready
to show some lives yes excellent we're
the right room total business to come
iPhone se you are awesome go think what
Samsung is the network is the most
important thing and I think that's
something you get from a bra weekend
like this you meet 200 like minded
people all going on the same adventure
so it's exciting stuff and well has a
very big heart and I can see that he's
got a heart so actually empower people
and I'm leaving at the end of a two-day
workshop feeling empowered feeling
blessed that I mean I I can actually do
it bubbling with confidence knowing that
um or the truth it's not for certain
people we just need to put your mind to
it and it can be done I know that you're
not here just to live a luxurious life
yes you're going to learn how to make
tens and tens of thousands of pounds but
you know what money's just a means to an
end when it's not a person when he's a
tool and as long as you hold it like
this with open hands and a generous
heart then god bless you if you hold it
like this
mine and there's a problem but a problem
with wrong with your heart it's possible
to make a lot of money out of property
and the penny suddenly drop that I was
never planning to hang on to it all
myself
I mean there are good causes that I want
to support and those who do get it will
deserve it
if you want to take it seriously if you
want to achieve something in life I'll
just take action there is no better time
than now I mean a year later from now
you're going to be regretting that you
didn't take actually a year back so if
anyone highly encouraged you just do it
there's literally no nothing holding
back you jump
[Music]
you